die atombomben auf hiroshima und
nagasaki
1945 bisher die einzigen im krieg
eingesetzten atomwaffen wir schauen
welche länder besitzen aktuell
atomwaffen
welche unterschiedlichen arten gibt es
wie viele atomwaffen sind unmittelbar
einsatzfähig wie werden die atomwaffen
aktiviert und wie soll ein atomares
aufrüsten verhindert werden
[Musik]
weltweit gibt es nach schätzungen der
siebte stiftung rund 13.100 atomwaffen
russland besitzt die meisten dieser
massenvernichtungswaffen und
6.250 die usa etwa
5.550 die übrigen verteilen sich auf die
offiziell anerkannten atommächte china
frankreich und großbritannien
außerdem besitzen pakistan indien israel
und nordkorea atomwaffen
die us amerikanischen atomwaffen sind
nicht nur in den usa stationiert etwa
150 bis 200 befinden sich in den nato
partner starten deutschland belgien den
niederlanden in italien und in der
türkei
und fast alle atomwaffen besitzen länder
können ihre waffen nicht nur von land
sondern auch durch flugzeuge und vom
meer aus zum beispiel mit hilfe von u
booten starten
[Musik]
atomwaffen werden unter anderem in die
kategorien strategisch und taktisch
eingeteilt die atomsprengköpfe
unterscheiden sich in ihrer größe und
auch wie sie zum einsatz gebracht werden
strategischer atomwaffen können über
große distanzen eingesetzt werden
mehrere tausend kilometer entfernte
ziele können damit getroffen werden sie
können weite gebiete zerstören
strategische atomwaffen werden mit
langstreckenraketen oder auch mit
mittelstreckenraketen
transportiert
taktische atomwaffen sind kleiner und
können mit hilfe von kurzstreckenraketen
im unmittelbaren gefecht eingesetzt
werden ihre sprengkraft ist deutlich
geringer als die der strategischen
atomwaffen verglichen mit der
sprengkraft konventioneller waffen ist
ihre zerstörungskraft trotzdem viel viel
größer
[Musik]
die anzahl der atomwaffen ist heute
deutlich geringer als in den 1970 ern
und mitte der 1980 er jahre dem
höhepunkt des wettrüstens zwischen den
usa und der sowjetunion damals gab es
etwa 70.000 atomwaffen deutlich mehr als
heute aber
gleichzeitig hat sich die zahl der
einsatzbereiten atomwaffen leicht erhöht
von den aktuell
13.100 ist also ein knappes drittel
montiert bzw bereits montage und damit
einsatzbereit
die usa halten wohl 1800 bereit russland
mindestens 1600 25
frankreich hält fast sein gesamtes
kontingent in bereitschaft und
großbritannien etwas mehr als die hälfte
neben der zahl der einsatzbereiten
waffen haben die staaten auch die
ausgaben zur modernisierung der
atomwaffen deutlich erhöht
[Musik]
in russland gilt ein vierstufige
planline militärische eskalation
stufe eins frieden stufe zwei die
truppen werden in erhöhte bereitschaft
versetzt
stufe 3 die waffen werden scharf gemacht
und hier kommen im übergang zur stufe 4
die umgangssprachlich atom koffer
genannten kommunikations und staat
systeme ins spiel von denen gibt es drei
neben dem präsidenten verfügt der
verteidigungsminister und der chef des
generalstabs über dieses thema stufe 4
bedeutet dann gegebenenfalls krieg mit
nuklearwaffen
auch in den usa gilt ein mehrstufiger
plan bei militärische eskalation der
allerdings wie ein countdown rückwärts
zählt stufe 5 frieden stufe 4 bedeutet
erhöhte geheimdiensttätigkeit und
bestimmte sicherheitsmaßnahmen
stufe 3 versetzt die armee in erhöhte
einsatzbereitschaft
stufe 2 die streitkräfte sind innerhalb
von maximal sechs stunden einsatzbereit
stufe eins alle streitkräfte sind
kampfbereit und nun kommt auch hier der
atom koffer zum einsatz es gibt
insgesamt drei stück und sie
funktionieren unabhängig voneinander
neben dem präsidenten und der
vize-präsidentin verfügt eine dritte
person über die notwendigen systeme
[Musik]
nach dem ende des kalten krieges war die
hoffnung groß dass das atomare
wettrüsten ein ende findet und die
bedrohungen damit deutlich sinkt ein
grund der atomwaffensperrvertrag von
1995 wurde er verlängert und bis heute
haben 191 staaten unterzeichnet für
diese unterzeichnerstaaten beschränkt er
die herstellung und den besitz von
atomwaffen auf die anerkannten
atommächte indien pakistan israel und
nordkorea haben diesen vertrag nie
unterzeichnet
beziehungsweise sie sind von ihm
zurückgetreten
in hinblick auf die atomare abrüstung
sind bis heute die bilateralen verträge
zwischen den usa und russland zentral
schließlich besitzen sie 90 prozent
aller atomwaffen
von 1987 bis 2009 10 wurde durch den
vertrag die reduzierung von atomwaffen
mit kürzerer und mittlerer reichweite
geregelt
1991 trat das start abkommen das tätig
arms reduction treaty in kraft 1
abrüstungsvertrag mit dem new start
abkommen von 2011 wurde und wird diese
abrüstungsprozess aktuell fortgesetzt
das gleichgewicht des schreckens
zwischen den usa und russland das
bewusstsein dass auf einen atomaren
erstschlag die eigene vernichtung folgt
ist eine strategie die lange
funktioniert habt im moment erscheint
sie einigen beobachtern angesichts
massiver russischer trunkenen abgibt